- [Narrator] Are you facing
a challenging dilemma
in your life right now?
The dilemma's a new Jubilee
show and we're looking
for people who are seeking
advice, willing to be vulnerable,
and anonymously sharing
their dilemmas on camera.
Click on the link in the description below
and share your dilemma.
- Would it be okay if I immersed myself
with you guys and also got naked?
- That's the whole point.
That's why we're here.
- Okay.
- Everyone should get naked.
- Okay, I'm wearing like the
hardest outfit to get naked.
You know, I feel actually
a lot more comfortable.
Do I just start asking questions?
(people giggle)
- [Narrator 2] If you
were alone in a room,
with people who are
nudists, what would you ask?
- Do you guys hug in the community?
- What are your thoughts
on raising children as nudists?
- Do you shave or your
kind of like, "F it,"?
(groovy music)
- I'm nervous, but hi
y'all, my name is Lance.
- Hi, Lance.
I'm Juliana, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, Juliana.
- I'm nervous too.
- I'm Tim, hi, Lance.
- Hi, nice to meet you, Tim.
Well, I just wanna first know,
do you guys know each other already?
- Yes, we're friends.
We met through stand up comedy, right?
- It's been so long.
Mutual nudist circles but we've done
nude standup comedy tours.
We made a naked movie together.
We've done all kinds of stuff.
- I didn't know they
had nude comedy tours.
That's interesting.
- Hell yeah.
(Lance and Juliana laugh)
Naked audience.
Naked comedians, absolutely.
- Well, I guess first of all,
are you guys naked right now?
- Yes.
- Yes, wonderful.
- Oh, no, I just realized.
- So I'm just curious.
What is the point of the nudist community?
Like what?
- To be naked?
(Juliana giggles)
- Okay.
- The definition of a
nudist is just someone
who enjoys being nude.
You don't have to go
into a nudist community.
You could just be naked at your house.
But there is a nudist
community, I would say,
because of everything else
that there's a community for.
You know?
So this is just a place
where you get to be
with other like-minded individuals
and also be comfortable
in a safe space naked.
- When did you start your nudist journey?
- It was my partner that
looked into it and says,
"You know, we're nudists."
And so that's when we started
checking out nude beaches.
So that was yeah, about 10, 11 years ago.
- When I was in college,
I was an art student
and I signed up to be a nude model
'cause I wanted to have that experience.
And that began me looking into
resorts and art for nudity.
- Got it.
- Like me, I leave a snail trail.
How do you keep things like sanitary?
(Juliana laughs)
- Oh dear.
- You know, we we're human, things happen
but that is a purpose of a towel.
It's always, it's just
- Standard etiquette.
Standard etiquette, there you go.
- The towel etiquette.
- What do you do if you get your period?
- What do you do when
you're on your period?
You just let the tampon hang?
(Juliana laughs)
- I'll answer this.
(all laugh)
- There are different things.
I personally don't use tampons.
They're just scary to me.
If you're a female that still
wants to go to a nude event
and you are on your period and
maybe you have to wear a pad,
I'm sure they'll be respectful
if you do have your bottoms on.
You won't be turned away for that reason.
- Within the community, like what's kind
of acceptable behavior?
Like, do you guys hug in the community?
Or is that like, people
don't really accept hugs or?
- No, it's normal.
I mean, I guess after COVID everybody
keeps a distance the
same way you would still.
I guess if you feel
comfortable hugging someone,
then you would, it
would be the same thing,
whether you're close or not.
- Right, it's comfort
level and appropriateness,
just like anything else.
- Yeah.
- Are there like secret meetup spots
for other nudists or is it
mostly like designated beaches?
- There are no secret meetups.
There are public organizations.
- Yeah, it's not a secret club, brother.
Like we're proud of it and we're active.
I am a lifetime member of
three large nude organizations
and there's non landed
groups that purposely will
for example, rent out a bowling
alley to have naked bowling
or naked boating out at the ocean.
There's naked skydiving.
I mean, there's a whole
world of naked lifestyle.
- Naked bowling sounds pretty sweet.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
- Yeah, we're all going after the shoot.
- I'll be there, I'll be there.
- Just keep your mind out the gutter.
- When people come over,
is it shoes off bra off?
Or like, is it up to everyone's discretion
when they start taking their clothes off?
- If you come to my
house, I'm not gonna open
the door naked.
I sure some people do that.
I don't.
- I do that.
I'm not a nudist.
- Why are you on that side?
- Tim, all right, so do
you ever get erections
at nudist events?
- A lot of these, these
are textile thoughts.
So nudists refer to people
who wear clothes as textiles.
The textiles think it's an
overly sexual experience,
but it's so not.
There's families and
kids and elderly folks.
And it's not a strip club.
If you happen to get an
erection, these things happen
and you are just, you don't flaunt it.
You put a towel over
it, you get in the pool,
you don't make a big deal out of it.
And it goes down.
So it's much less an
issue than a lot of men
like to hang onto.
- If it sounded weird
when I was coming in,
I'm in a wheelchair, so.
- Oh.
- I wonder, are there a
lot of disabled nudists
or is it racially diverse?
- I, at least I don't think
there are many disabled
in the nudist community
or at least out in public,
as well as even the whole
female and male ratio.
There's more male involved.
So that is something that we want to see,
especially me as a female,
I would love to see more
women involved in nudism.
It is a safe space.
- Diversity in the nudist
community in America,
it's very fat white men, I would say.
And as a fat white man
sitting here, I'm telling you,
we want to embrace all the
different types of folks.
And we would love more people to come
and get involved and experience it.
And so we're hoping to,
one person at a time.
- Would you say that there's a certain age
that participates in this community more?
- The average age for nudists is over 55.
- Okay.
- By and large, it is 55 plus.
And the reason for that is
because at that point you've retired.
You don't care what people say about you.
It doesn't affect your job.
So at that point, they're
able to finally embrace
who they are, which I think is sad.
I wish that people would be
able to stand up and say,
"This is who I am," younger
and at an earlier age.
- What's the biggest
riff in the community.
- May I?
Riff as in internal fighting?
- Yes.
- Yeah, it would be imposters.
It would be fake nudists.
It would be resorts that claim to be,
"We are non-sexual family friendly,"
and then Tuesday is swinger night.
And so us in the industry, that
makes us look awful and bad.
And like, it really sucks
for any organization
to find some people who don't live
up to the ideals that we all preach.
- If I ask a question,
our children allowed,
and the answer is no, it
probably is not a nudist resort,
it's something more.
Because nudism should include children.
- Do you guys think it's appropriate
for children to be naked
in front of adults?
- [Both] Yes.
- Yes, this is nonsexual and we mean that,
nonsexual lifestyle.
- Right.
- And it's affirming.
It's good for self-esteem.
And for saying, "You're
fine the way you are
and this is what bodies look like."
- Do you guys have kids?
And if so, would you want your kids
to follow your same footsteps?
- I don't have kids and I
don't plan on having children
but I do think it is a healthy lifestyle.
I do have a nephew and he
knows about our lifestyle.
I don't hang around with him naked.
He is underage and he's not my child.
When he turns 18, and he asks
me, "I wanna try nudism."
Then I would guide him.
- Yeah, I also don't
have any kids on my own,
but I'm Uncle Tim to bazillion kids.
And more than just the kids,
I've watched what the kids turn into.
So I've seen the generations
of, I knew this kid nudist,
now they're grown with
kid nudists of their own.
And so I've seen the positive effects
of good body image and education.
Not worrying about
naughty parts, dirty parts
but knowing, "Oh, that's
what that looks like."
It's not a big deal.
- I definitely agree with that.
Yeah, I feel like, especially
like in today's society,
it's like, "Oh, well you should cover up.
Like your nipples are showing."
- Yeah, I mean, that's
a basic human right.
Talk freedom, I can be
topless, and you can't.
- Yeah.
- How, how fair is that?
How does that make sense in any world?
- Exactly.
- Sexism.
- Do people ever take photos or videos
of you like at nudist
beaches or nudist places?
- There is a nudist bike ride.
Well, it's international,
but they do one here
in Los Angeles once a year.
It gets really irritating.
It's open to the public and anyone
that wants to go can go.
And of course it's mostly men.
Some men just go just to go take pictures.
They're not even riding a bike.
So, but it's so much fun.
I mean, you get to ride
naked in the city of LA.
I mean, so it's like, I want to do it,
but it gets really discouraging.
- This is really for me.
What advice would you give to someone
that's struggling to feel
comfortable in their body?
- If that is the reason
that you do want choose
to try nudism to feel more comfortable
and have better self-esteem,
in my personal experience,
I felt it did do that for me.
I just remember the very first
day I went to a nudist beach
and I was like, "Oh my
God, nobody's perfect.
And they don't care,
so why should I care?"
So I do think it helps in that aspect.
- That's amazing.
I feel like me personally, I've struggled
before with like body images
and like how my body looks
like in the mirror and stuff like that.
Sometimes like I would take a shower
with like the lights off,
'cause I didn't wanna see
my body after like, and stuff like that.
- The way I try to tell
people, or I talk myself
is whatever hang up you
have about yourself,
somebody else has that as well.
You're not alone.
It's normal.
It's life, it's human.
We're human.
We have, I guess it's hard to explain.
- We're humans having a human experience.
- There it is.
- If we can try to have
some radical empathy
and help each other along the way,
then that's what we've found
in the nudist community.
It's come as you are.
And then be embraced and
loved the way you are.
- Yeah.
- Wonderful.
- I have like one more.
I was gonna just say like, do you shave?
Or you're kind of like it, "F it"?
- Hey now.
(Juliana laughs)
- I guess personal choice.
I personally don't shave my lady parts.
This year I stopped shaving my under arm,
but I shaved today, so it's just,
I guess how I feel that day.
But I'm personally someone
who doesn't completely
shave down there.
- I had a bro-zilian recently where I had
everything everything done.
- Everything's gone.
- I was terrified.
I was sweating.
I was like, "Oh God," but I don't,
and it is up for personal preference.
- Yeah.
- So people do whatever
they feel comfortable doing.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, I think you
guys kind of changed my mind
about it, 'cause I'm always like at home
just naked and I'd rather
do that outside of it.
- Oh, you're a nudist.
- Yeah.
- And that's it.
You don't have to do it in public,
but it's nice to meet other
like-minded individuals.
You will get to know people and I'm sure,
make lifelong friends.
I mean, we've been friends forever now.
- A decade, yeah.
It'd be funny if when we meet her,
she's naked on the other side.
- I know.
- You are one of us.
- [Narrator 2] If y'all
want to introduce, meet,
you can.
- Yay.
- I want to, but do I really want to?
(Juliana laughs)
- Yeah, okay.
- But it goes both ways, maybe
we don't want you to see us.
- Maybe we don't want to,
we don't wanna see you.
- Yeah, how about that, Lance?
Like it's a big, frickin'.
Lance, what's up man?
Good to see you.
- You guys make it like so normal.
- [Juliana And Tim] It is.
(Juliana laughs)
- SCNA is a great option.
The Southern California
Nature's Association
- I'm there.
- That would be great.
(Juliana laughs)
- Hang out with us.
I'm glad you took part in this, man.
I hope you learned something.
- Thank you.